we've teamed up this week with digital
media company refinery29 for our series
my vote we polled millennial Women
Voters to explore their potential impact
on the upcoming midterm elections about
one-third of women ages 18 to 35 say
headlines over the past year motivated
them to become more engaged in politics
but only 30 percent of millennial women
say they will definitely vote in the
midterms this fall as part of our my
vote series we followed two politically
active millennial women on opposite
sides of the aisle to learn what
motivates them my name is Vanessa Rivera
and I am 23 years old people just think
that because I'm young woman and Spanish
that I just checked the box to think
more of a liberal point of view and that
just is not the case I am registered
Republican
[Music]
I'm Micah Scharf I'm 25 years old
politics was always a dinner table
conversation with my family I am
registered as a Democrat I have been
very fascinated by politics since I was
little I got more involved in college
when I joined the College Republicans
keep them motivated and I got called a
Hispanic hater I got called a
brainwashed Baptist and that just made
me feel like I wasn't being hurt until I
just like go parked in here and walk I
never really thought I would end up in
politics and sometimes I still wonder
what I'm doing in this political sphere
but after the whole 2016 cycle I just
knew that there was something missing
and there was a just a desperate need
for new leadership in public service we
also have a really big lineup today I
think the girls are active from about
8:30 in the morning till about I want to
shave 10 o'clock at night
all right ladies sigh and the campus
program associate for the network of
enlightened women today we're doing a
lot of professional development the
network of and land women is a nonprofit
organization that has chapters all
across the United States where college
women aren't able to discuss ideological
differences from a conservatives point
of view every day I get to wake up and
they get to give people an opportunity
to change their communities
I am the finance director for Ken
Harbaugh for Congress my
responsibilities include planning
fundraising events he sits on two
committees engaging with our thousands
of supporters zero
like writing emails to potential new
supporters whirlen hello this is Ken
Harbaugh with Cadiz he makes phone calls
bread crusts attending a meet-and-greet
knocking on doors the fact that I'm
bilingual and immigration I think is
something that will always be near and
dear to my heart due to the fact that my
mother is an immigrant and so is my
grandmother my grandmother just became a
citizen last year that's them right
there we're living in a world where
folks have to choose between going to
the grocery and paying for health care
sorry and that doesn't make sense
to me it doesn't make sense to I think
most Millennials I do not think
Millennials are doing enough politically
for an internship of you know foreign
policy and things like that
put it in there I know of a ton of
college students that we can post online
about their outrage of what their
congressman their Senators or the
president are doing but they didn't even
vote in the last election they're gonna
go visit some union halls they're gonna
do well Neos did not vote in 2016 we
just didn't show up but I think you're
gonna see in a big way that Millennials
will be engaged in 2018 and beyond when
I look at young women today I feel
optimistic 2018 is the year of the woman
we're gonna continue to change the world
to a young woman more connected to the
Democratic Party I would tell them
listen to us chat with us talk to us try
and see our point of view including more
women across the aisle involved and
honestly
let's grab coffee let's talk about the
things that matter to us and if you put
a few more women in these rooms making
decisions I think we'd get a lot more
done
both sides say you've got a vote though
it's a little disturbing to hear that
only 30% say they definitely plan to
vote yeah those young women on both
sides are saying you've got to get
engaged get involved it's been great to
hear their voice is this we can march
you but they have to vote that's right